welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
rings of power season one welcome back
to Middle Earth for the Lord of the
Rings prequel many thousands of years
ago the elves lived in their own
Paradise place valinor but one day the
light of their tree started dying
because the dark lord morgoth started
dark lording so the elves had to leave
their homeland of valinor and sailed to
Middle Earth to fight him it was an epic
war but in the end they defeated morgoth
at Great cost our main character is the
elf Galadriel yeah who's still alive in
Lord of the Rings because remember elves
are Immortal unless of course they're
killed like galadriel's brother was by
morgoth's top General Sauron so she
swears to get revenge and that's where
this story picks up with Galadriel out
hunting for Sauron now in Lord of the
Rings she was real calm peaceful
Galadriel but in her youth she was an
epic Warrior oh yeah she tracks or onto
this Fortress where apparently he was
trying to Smith something but except for
his strange pitchfork logo the trail
runs cold so she goes home to elf City
where her best friend is elrond yeah
he's a youngster here too now Galadriel
wants to keep on hunting Sauron but the
elf King's like yo he's clearly gone the
war is over we're disbanding the
military so galadriel's forced into
retirement being shipped back off to
their Paradise continent valinor but at
the last minute she's like yeah no
thanks she bails off the boat she knows
Sauron is still out there and indeed
evil is secretly rising in the peaceful
Southlands the humans here sided with
morgoth back in the war so the elves are
still keeping a close eye on them it's
this guy's job Aaron dear but now orders
come in evil is gone the Army's
disbanded which is too bad for him
because he's got a flirtation going with
the human here Bronwyn luckily he has an
excuse to stick around when a cow gets
sick which leads him to discover the
next Village over has been destroyed and
he's captured by Orcs and they've
already dug tunnels under our village a
orc sneak attack luckily she manages to
take this one out like hey southlanders
time to evacuate meanwhile elrond has
been recruited for a special Mission by
the master Elvin Smith Cala brimbor he
wants to build a super special new Forge
but the elves can't do it alone they
need help from the dwarves so elrond
goes to the Dwarven city of Kaza Doon
currently in its golden age now elrond
friends with the Dwarven princeier Duran
but duren's mad at him at the moment
because he hasn't called in 40 years so
the best bros have to work it out by
Smashing some rocks together then he
brings him home to meet his new wife who
is super nice and these two are super
cute together and so these two are best
friends again the dwarves agree to help
and there's one more group we're
following the season the harfoots little
people that are peaceful and happy and
very clearly ancestors of Hobbits here
we follow a young mischievous harfoot
named Nori who likes going on adventures
with her best friend poppy one night a
meteor crashes nearby but it's no space
Rock it's a naked man who's this guy is
it Sauron well he definitely has some
magic powers he's kind of a man baby at
the moment doesn't know how to talk or
be human so Nori befriends him tries to
help him out and I'm pretty sure this
dude's Gandalf so out in the middle of
the ocean galadriel's starting to think
she's made a huge mistake luckily she
finds a random raft of humans one who's
this hot guy Hal brand but almost
immediately a sea monster attacks kills
the rest of them so she and albrand gets
him alone time and they do the thing
where they don't get along at first so
you know they're gonna hook up later but
now they're picked up by a real boat and
brought to the legendary Island King
Kingdom of numenor their ancestors sided
with the elves against morgoth in the
war so they were granted this beautiful
island but right now the political
climate is anti-elf so Galadriel and the
queen don't get along she's put under
house arrest and guarded by the sea
captain who found her alendil alendil
wait why do I know that name well you
might know my more famous son isildor
yes ancestor of Aragorn and the guy who
well no spoilers I guess if you haven't
seen Lord of the Rings for now though
he's a brass young man who wants to drop
out of boat college to go adventuring in
Middle Earth but his father is like son
you can't drop out of boat college to be
an adventurer ironically though he has
no problem with his daughter going to
art school anyway galadriel's house
arrest includes the library where she
discovers she's been holding sore on
symbol sideways it's not a pitchfork
it's a map of the Southlands and this is
an interesting coincidence because her
new friend Hal brand has this pouch with
a symbol on it that is the Royal symbol
of the Southlands yes he's doing the
Aragorn thing where he's the long lost
King but he doesn't want it because his
ancestors sided with the bad guys in the
Southlands the Orcs have taken arendere
prisoner but he stages a Prison Break
and he's got those leg loss elf
superpowers yeah in the end he's caught
again and brought before the orc leader
oh man that's definitely Sauron but he
claims not to be Sauron he's like I'm a
totally different guy my name's Adar
meanwhile the humans have evacuated to
the elf Tower but they're running out of
food so bronwyn's doofus son goes back
to the Village to find some but he also
finds a Super Evil looking sword that if
you put your blood in it becomes Shadow
sword more on that later anyway Adar let
elf guy go to bring a message surrender
or die Bronwyn steps up to be a leader I
vote we fight but this coward bartender
guys like no I vote we surrender he
takes a group to the Orcs like hey we
pledge allegiance to you Lord Sauron
adar's like bro I'm telling you I'm not
Sauron really back in elf land the
construction projects going great with
the Newfound cooperation between dwarves
and elves but elrond suspects both sides
are hiding something he asks his friend
Duran who's like okay but you gotta
promise not to tell cause we found this
new metal that is like super cool we
call it mithril only problem is it's
super dangerous to mine in fact the
tunnel collapses right now and turns out
the elves know all about this role
that's the real reason they said Delran
in the first place see way back in the
age of Legends some dude was fighting a
balrog and like the power of the Gods
went into this tree which then seeped
down into the mountains made mithril and
now for unknown reasons the elves are
losing their immortality their only hope
is that the mithril can reinvigorate it
that's what the super Forge is for they
want to make a bunch of mithril for like
all the elves to wear so elrond tells
Duran hey we need your help and it's
like hey bro I got you but it's not
Duran they need to convince it's Duran's
father the king Duran senior and he's
like look mining the mithril is too
dangerous I'm not gonna risk Dwarven
lives to save the elves who you know
it's unfair they're Immortal anyway but
duren's not gonna let his best friend
die so these two go down to mine it
themselves and they succeed they find
the mithril motherlode going way down to
the mountain just then though duren's
dad catches him and he's none too
pleased he banishes elrond and strips
his Honduran of his princely caller he
shuts down the mithril mining it's just
too dangerous and ironically he's
totally right because down in the depths
they might wake in an ancient evil yeah
the balrog he doesn't wake up this
season though but watch out for him in
season two now back to the the hard
foots they're getting ready for their
big migration but Nori's dad breaks his
ankle and normally Harvard's all stick
together but on the migration it's the
pirate's code if you fall behind you're
left behind but luckily Nori's new
friend hobo Gandalf is here to help him
push their cart and these two Bond have
great times she teaches him how to speak
words and he's a real helpful guy not
just for pushing carts but if wolves
attack for Dew and Magic on him but
sometimes he can't control his powers he
oh almost accidentally hurts Nori and
there's another Peril closing in behind
them because this strange group of
people are tracking our space man now
back to Galadriel who wants numenor's
help to go save the Southlands from
Sauron but the queen here is like sorry
can't help you she shows Galadriel the
palantir she has this one shows the
future where galadriel's arrival ends
with new Manor's destruction swallowed
by the Sea so yeah you see it's not
personal but you gotta get out of here
but just then their Magic Tree starts
shedding leaves which is as good a sign
as any that you're on the wrong path so
now Queen Muriel's like change of plans
new Menorah we're helping Galadriel
sailing off to war but the make newmanor
great again movement is not happy about
this and their leader is Chancellor
farazon and he's a really good
politician manages to calm this crowd
and get them on board with the war but
also somehow make it about vote for me
and this guy has an absolutely glorious
beard hair combo something which his son
Kevin uh does not he's been flirting
with the silver sister and generally
seems like a nice guy but he reveals
he's kind of a douche like Hey Dad we
hate elves why do you support this war
it's like first off Kevin get a haircut
and secondly if we sail to war and save
the Southlands we can rule the
Southlands will be England middle
Earth's America it'll be awesome and so
it's happening Galadriel in full shiny
armor sailing off with new Manor to save
the Southlands and not a moment too soon
cause a Dar and the Orcs are Marching on
the Village Health guys that's a home
alone trap for him at the tower yeah
take that but there's always more Orcs
now they're fighting at the Village all
peasants versus orc fight in the end the
peasants win until they realize these
Orcs they fought were the people that
defected yeah he sent them first then
Nadar rolls up with the full Arc Army
and easily seduce him now he really
wants the shadow sword and to save his
mom the kid gives it up but wait now
who's this coming yes the Newman or
cavalry riding in nothing like a cavalry
charge to save the day and a sildor by
the way is here too he gets his wish to
fight in the battle and have a grand
Adventure galadrio pulls off a sick move
where she Dodges an arrow outside of the
horse yeah take that this other guy
tries to copy her but he doesn't quite
have that Elven core strength so Adar is
trying to escape with the sword but Hal
bran shows he's got the ab strength to
get down there oh trip the horse and now
galadriel's interrogating him like so
come on you're Sauron right but he's
like no I'm telling you I'm a different
person Sauron abandoned us to go off
blacksmithing so it's up to me to try to
give our people a home remember in Lord
of the Rings how soromon explained that
the Orcs used to be elves that were
corrupted by dark Powers well that's me
I'm the first one of those and that's
why I kind of look like an elf still but
I really am an orc and it's an
interesting moral flip here as he's like
look I just want a Homeland for my
people we oryx have as much right to
live as anyone else and gladial's the
one who's like nah Orcs are a pure evil
and ugly I'm gonna genocide you all
anyway for now the Southlands are saved
and good news we found your long-lost
king and these peasants haven't invented
democracy yet so they're like oh this is
amazing all hail King albrand but now
what's the deal with this Shadow sword
Well turns out to DAR did a Switcheroo
gave the real sword to the bartender guy
who else sticks it in the thing turns
out it's a key that opens the dam and
releases the river and all these tunnels
the Orcs were digging were not just to
hide turns out they all lead to the
mountain a mountain that's actually a
volcano and now with the water added
boom and it's not a small eruption with
a little bit of lava it's a massive
Mount Saint Helens wall of smoke and
death uh no bueno for the Southlands
this was a DARS master plan to create
the land of permanent Shadow perfect for
the Orcs And in case you hadn't realized
it yet the Southlands are Mordor
gladriel survives because she's got
super elf powers and doofus kid survives
too because he's got super plot Powers
his hot mom survives too along with his
hot new Elven stepdad the queen survives
too although she is blind now but it's
isildor who was down in a burning
building when how it collapsed on him
because this is a prequel we know a
sildor lives but his dad oh so sad so
numenor is going to retreat for now but
the queen vows to come back with an even
bigger Army and gladriel's like nice
I'll get the elves on board too and so
as the important people go off to do
important things uh the cephalon
villagers are gonna rebuild I guess
Slightly North of the Southlands now the
harfoots are approaching their rest stop
the beautiful Apple Grove but
unfortunately it's close to the
Southlands torched by the volcano maybe
Gandalf tries to magically save some
trees but all he manages to do is almost
kill some hard foots so it's finally
like hey man thanks and I'm sorry but
maybe you are too dangerous to keep
around but the next day turns out his
magic worked the apples are saved yeah
you feel bad for sending them off now
but now Eminem has caught up to him and
it's like wait who are you bu Friend or
Foe they don't say anything but they
liked all the Apple carts on fire oh
they Foe for the hard foots this is an
extinction level event but Nori's Dad
gives a speech about sticking together
which makes Nori realize I gotta go save
Gandalf because indeed The Real Slim
Shady has caught up to him but they're
not here to fight him they're here to
serve him they think he is Sauron
they're gonna take him to a special
place where you can see this
constellation nation and he'll get his
memories and his powers back but his
hard foot friends are here to rescue him
unfortunately they're no match for
Fireballs nor he's like hey man we need
your help but he's feeling bad because
now he thinks he's evil and it's like
dude good and evil aren't something
you're born with you can choose to be
whoever you want and so he chooses good
stands up for his hard foot friends
these guys are like oh it's not Sauron
he's the other one yeah bro I told you
I'm Gandalf boom banished and so for the
hard foots the day is saved uh except
Old Village Elder guy he dies now back
to the elves where Galadriel and elrond
fill each other in while Hal brand hangs
out at their cool new Forge turns out he
is something of a Smith himself he's
like wow what's this cool metal but it's
like hey don't touch that it's expensive
and it's the only mithril we have it's
like hey I know you're the master smith
Cala brimbor but I mean I just had the
idea what if you mixed it with some
other metals to you know spread it out
and calabrimbo is super embarrassed he
didn't think of that so they have a new
plan with this much mithril they can
make one Crown if the Elven King wears
it it can maybe radiate light to all the
elves keep him Immortal but as Cala
brimbor explains what they're trying to
do it sounds exactly like what a dog R
told her Sauron was trying to do and now
she's looking at her friend Hal brand
very suspiciously which is awkward
because this would be a fantastic time
to make out if she didn't suspect him of
being a dark lord and now she finds
proof that the line of Southland Kings
is confirmed ended it's like who are you
really and he goes full Breaking Bad say
my name dark lord Sauron you're goddamn
right she tries to kill him but he traps
her in a raft dream where it's like look
I'm not a bad guy if you re-watch the
season I never lied to you my story is
the same as Hal Brands I used to serve
more goth but now I'm free to be better
his plan is to make two magic crowns and
save Middle Earth with him and Galadriel
ruling together he's like hey baby I
won't be a dark lord if you're by my
side the Lady of Light but she's not
having it she's like look clearly you
are Super Evil and he's like yeah I mean
yeah maybe I am so he disappears but
gladriel decides not to tell her friends
it's Sauron who's been helping him
because the elves still need this
mithril but now she has a new idea One
Crown is bad because it could corrupt
that person and two is bad because it
could corrupt them both in the war they
need three three super elves that can
find balance but it's like hey we don't
have enough mithril for three crowns we
need something smaller and so the
forging of the three Elven rings has
begun as season one comes to an end the
hard foots are gonna finish their
migration except for Nori who's gonna go
on an adventure she's gonna be the
sidekick for her new Wizard Trend and
even though they never say Gandalf yet
he starts talking exactly like him it's
obviously Gandalf the numenorians make
it back to find out her father the King
has finally died and if House of the
Dragon has taught us anything the death
of a king is a good excuse for
counselors to start scheming also if
sildor's Sister happened to be with the
king in his final moments where he was
lucid and was like you gotta read the
prophecy ball so now she knows that and
the forging of the Rings is complete yes
we've got the three Elven rings of power
but with collateral acting weird elron
did some snooping and found out Sauron
was helping him but he also doesn't say
anything he comes to the same conclusion
that it'll be fine as long as Sauron
doesn't I don't know in secret forge a
master ring to rule them all which is of
course exactly what he's gonna do and
that is where the rings of power season
one comes to an end
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]